[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ambiance des grands jours à versailles
3000 supporters habillés de blanc et
bleu aux couleurs des sang et or se sont
donné rendez vous au stade mont boron
objectif encourager leurs protégés lors
de ce 8e tour de coupe de france entre
versailles et lens a tous voulu venir
soutenir fc versailles
c'est contre ans aujourd'hui c'est
historique et du coup aux côtes en est
là aujourd'hui et l'ambiance est montée
d'un cran à l'entrée des joueurs
les versaillais qui évolue en n3 font
jeu égal avec lens club de ligue 2 les
deux équipes rejoignent les vestiaires
dos à dos après un deuxième but
versailles est marqué par chalali juste
avant la mi temps
sans la magie la coupe de france tout le
monde est mobilisé le public et surtout
les joueurs qui font une super première
mi temps et on espère qu'on passera
devant en deuxième mi temps
juste avant la mi-temps espère que ça va
tomber alors taper sur la tête et on va
tout donner pour nous un tri but pour
que le troisième but arrive sur le
terrain en deuxième période malgré le
bruit des tambours et des chants dans
les tribunes les lensois accéléré marque
deux buts pour l'emporter 4 à 2 fin de
l'aventuré pour ces courageux verser
malgré tout y est la défaite aucun décès
n est pas ce qu ont abordé ce match là
pour pour le remporter
on n'a pas remporté ce match mais je
tiens à saluer le courage l'abnégation
et le coeur que mes joueurs ont mis sur
ce match au fil du match
cette seconde mi temps on a on a pris un
but assez vite mais on a on a baissé
physiquement et c'est là où c'était plus
dur pour nous après l'élimination de
versailles les yvelinois ne compte plus
aucun représentant en coupe de france
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour vivre
de nouvelles émotions
[Applaudissements]